des voitures des voitures et encore des
voitures à paris l'histoire a commencé
avec la politique du tout auto du
premier ministre georges pompidou dans
les années 60
paris est vraiment trop voyantes à
partir de 1970 les piétons veulent aussi
se faire une place dans la capitale il
participe à une expérience menée par la
préfecture de police de paris
trois artères sont interdites aux
voitures pendant quatre jours avec
maxime bonini c'est qu'il est pour vous
monsieur quelques présidents
d'associations les pieds quand c'est un
triomphe alors nous avons déjà obtenu
beaucoup de rues réservées aux piétons
cet avis tout le monde ne partage pas
les commerçants rechignent inquiet de
voir leur clientèle potentiellement
disparaître j'estime que dans le
faubourg ce n'est pas une clientèle de
piétonnes nous avons mais une clientèle
qui est en retrait avec chauffeur jeunes
seront pop soul alam
autre expérience de piétonnisation à
paris en 1974 rue saint-andré-des-arts
dans le 6e arrondissement
mais là encore des obstacles les parent
qui manque aux alentours difficile pour
les riverains de se garer résultats
parfois des esprits s'échauffent
va chez moi c'est un client de l'hôtel
s'il rentrera
moi je vais au commissariat vous venez
avec moi j'en ai marre de tout votre
corps inona no no no no les années
suivantes
d'autres zones deviennent piétonnes dans
la capitale le quartier beaubourg en 76
ou encore les quais de seine en 1994
pour la première fois la mairie de paris
expérimenté une journée sans voiture une
initiative saluée par ce cycliste il
devrait donc augmenter plus souvent
parce que nous allons sûrement le fait
dans le bal boulogne le fait un petit
peu à versailles mais visiter paris
cette manière c'est valable
l'appel est entendu et 7 quito nisation
de paris va même plus loin en 1998
pendant une journée
la voiture est bannie de 28 zones de la
capitale depuis 2015
cette journée sans voiture est devenue
annuelle est encore une fois ces
initiatives ne font pas toujours
l'unanimité
bonjour excusez moi non
ça convienne vraiment rien aujourd'hui
la mairie de paris veut repousser un peu
plus les automobiles du coeur de la
capitale depuis le 12 mai une
consultation est en ligne sur internet
pour piétonniser le centre de paris
d'ici 2022
[Musique]